well in 2019 we interviewed the
secretary of homeland security on this
show kirsten nielsen
and we asked does the government have
any idea just how many illegal aliens
live in this country politicians have
claimed for more than 10 years that
there are 11 million of them do we
really know
watch does the us government know
exactly how many people are living in
this country
illegally i've seen academic studies
that put that number between
11 million 22 million maybe more what is
the real number
uh we debate it i mean i think that's
accurate so we don't question it we do
not know
that must be a grave concern to you that
we potentially have more than 10 million
people
here whose identities we don't know
could be over 20
um whose identities we don't know and
like they could be anybody
yes and so why is that not the single
most pressing problem the country has
in my opinion right now this is one of
if not the biggest crisis this country
has faced in a decade
so the best estimate we have the firmest
puts the number at about 22 million
people living here illegal there are
informed estimates that put the s
to put the number above 30 million
anyone who repeats the 11 million number
is either ignorant or lying but today no
matter what the number is the bidet
administration committed to making
every one of these foreign nationals
living here illegally into a voting
citizen
so we have no idea how many there are
but the bite administration wants to
introduce tens of millions of people
into the labor force to compete for jobs
with americans as quickly as possible
certainly as part of the proposal that
the president outlines
and proposed on day one is an earned
path to citizenship
right for uh 11 million uh immigrants
who are
undocumented immigrants who are living
in the country
again the 11 million number is a lie
do not let it pass without questioning
it
but no matter what the number is
more than 10 million new voters is going
to change the political balance of this
country
dramatically and it will disempower some
people quite a bit
not all of them republicans possibly
african-american voters if you think it
through a little bit
but if you ask congresswoman yvette
clark of new york
amnesty is great news for
african-american voters
this comprehensive immigration bill
would give dreamers
and tps ded holders a pathway to
citizenship
never forget that immigration is a black
issue exclamation point
she never explained what she meant by
that of course it's a lie and a total
betrayal for voters
unrestricted immigration hurts all
americans but it especially hurts people
at the bottom of the income scale
according to a 2006 study by a top
economist at harvard university
immigration dramatically lowered the
employment rate of african-american men
and increased their incarceration rate
those are not small things and that's
not even touching on the question of
political power which is a real question
congressman burgess owens joins us
tonight to assess
all of this congressman i appreciate
your coming on tonight i just find it
absolutely amazing
that labor unions and leaders of the
congressional black caucus
could endorse something that so
obviously hurts their own members
why do you think they're doing this well
what we have to understand is what the
real
thrill threat to the hard left and
growing up in a
remarkably successful segregated but
middle class family in the 60s and went
across our country in terms of our
in terms of black community the greatest
threat to the left is a middle-class
black american
those who have have faith they have a
family
they're educated and they believe in a
god and they believe in the free market
uh what what what's happened to my
community and by the way these
the leftists have never been our friends
they're the ones that are anti-choice
they're the ones that open borders that
they know
that's going to end up hurting those
that are trying to get that first ladder
up to the middle class
they're uh they're they're they're
against anything any policy that helps
us to become independent
and that is what that's what the left is
trying to do to our country so
i i want to be the the greatest uh
warning boy
to let you know from from a community
that was remarkably competitive
uh the most competitive in our country
during the 60s that is now
not so imp not competitive because of
what the left has done
what they've done to us is a preview of
what they're trying to do in our country
so we need to wake up americans doesn't
matter democrat independent republicans
it doesn't matter
what party those who love our nation
knows that there's a they need to know
there's a
leftist uh uh ideology that hates
everything we stand for
and they're coming at us big time we
need to pull ourselves together start
communicating
and realize that the policies that
biden's putting together right now is
all about defeating
the dream of americans to live the
american dream and get to the middle
class
i got to ask you congressman quickly
what percentage of actual black voters
do you think are in favor of giving
amnesty to foreign nationals here
illegally giving them voting rights
and benefits is that super popular among
black folks no no
it's a very very small minority of those
who get to have a chance to have this
conversation only the black elitists
those are the ones that have really done
the most damage those who live the
american dream
the black caucus right now that
literally of the american dream and tell
the wrestlers we can't do it
they're all about doing anything they
can to keep the
the the lowest the those are trying to
get the middle class
uh dependent so that the the elitist
class gets more power
and no matter what color they are uh
elitists are the workers the worst
threat to our nation no matter what
color and the worst of those who
look like me and tell black americans
like myself we can't do what others
americans do because
whatever our skin color or whatever
their excuse might be
the dream of america is we can overcome
all obstacles we need to make sure we're
spreading that news big time
it's such a betrayal one of many but a
bad one congressman owens of utah great
to see you tonight thank you
thank you thank you tucker